this Net Zero plan is not actually about
saving the climate or avoiding the world
from being destroyed it is a political
decision that is used to crack down on
people's freedom and people's rights
hello and welcome to martial matters
with me Winston Marshall at The
Spectator offices in London you might
have seen since 2019 the Dutch Farmers
have been
taking the tractors to the highways
their hay bales stacking up across the
roads protesting various government
policies against the so-called nitrogen
crisis and this week newly formed
political party representing the farmers
have won 17 seats in the Dutch Senate
becoming the largest party in the Senate
and to discuss what's happening and to
give me a history of the protests is
political activist a woman that you
might have seen at the Forefront of some
of those protests but also a legal
scholar a journalist and a political
commentator Ava
vladinger's broke
next correctly yeah no no no that was
good Ava thank you so much for taking
the time to speak with me thank you
thank you for having me so I understand
you're in London actually uh as part of
a debate on Net Zero which I think is
probably related to this topic so
hopefully we can get into that
absolutely yeah yes yeah
um but before that I was hoping we could
get into the Dutch Pharma protests and
what exactly is happening in the
Netherlands and um I believe a good
possible starting point would be 2019
when the first policies from the
government were introduced with the
intention of halving Dutch livestock
right um to battle the so-called
nitrogen crisis is that correct that's
correct yeah you're already obviously
very well read on the subject because
it's true this is a fight that has been
going on for quite a few years now so it
was in 2019 that the Dutch government
decided that nitrogen was a problem
um and in the years before that actually
they said that phosphate was the problem
so from 2015 to 2019 it was phosphate
and then they um they shifted to the the
focus to to nitrogen and so nitrogen
emissions had to be cut that was the the
entire idea and the farmers were the
ones that were you know according to the
government the largest group responsible
for the nitrogen emissions and therefore
they would have to well cut down in size
drastically and eventually even you know
we'll we'll get into that but maybe even
be expropriated so can we talk about the
nitrogen crisis what what is the crisis
so what I've understood is that uh the
Netherlands is the second highest
average gross nitrogen balance on
agriculture land in kilograms per
hectare the Netherlands is the second
highest and with almost twice the
average European country and uh so
what's the problem with nitrogen and um
uh what what is this so-called crisis
well exactly so-called crisis so I don't
even think that we should be calling it
a crisis at all you know really it's a
political decision it's a crisis that I
think only exists on paper because if
you really look at you know like
nitrogen deposition what really is the
problem there so I might get technical
for a little bit easier but I think it's
important to know so the Dutch
government is basing its nitrogen
policies on European legislation on EU
legislation and that is the Natura or
the nature 2000
um like regulation from the EU and that
regulation is about designated areas all
over Europe that are supposed to be
basically natural preserves you know
that you need to protect and in the
Netherlands we have 162 of those and
well anybody who's ever been to my
country knows it's you know obviously
it's very tiny and you know we're not
really known for our
um our Landscapes or you know advanced
nature there or or well you you know you
know we're the for the low lands a lot
of our land is agricultural it's not
exactly that people come to Holland for
the amazing forests or the natural
reserves or whatever it's like someone
took a rolling pin to the whole country
right yeah yeah and it's actually true
because I mean the Netherlands 80 of our
land is actually is Farmland so and
we're very densely populated so I'm not
surprised obviously that we have
compared to other European countries for
example High nitrogen emissions because
we're such a tiny country and
everything's so packed together and we
have a lot of Farmland
um because we are the second largest
exporter of agricultural products in the
world that's important context I think
because it's you're second behind the
United States but you're currently the
size of I think Maryland and the most
not only the most efficient farmers in
the world but without question the most
efficient Farmers to ever grace the
planet and I think I saw one uh fact
that the uh the average farmer takes 22
uh
liters of water to to produce a pound of
tomatoes whereas the Dutch farmers can
do it in half a liter or something oh no
gallons sorry gallons half a gallon
um and and you've pioneered vertical
farming and there's something like the
area of two Manhattan's worth of
greenhouses
um in in Netherlands so you are
leading the world in in in the farming
in agriculture absolutely absolutely
yeah that's really important to know you
know where we've been a farming Nation
for centuries so a lot of the people uh
that are farmers today you know it's not
just them it's their their their
ancestors their their grandparents their
grand grandparents so it's knowledge
that has built up over centuries and
they are incredibly good at it so yeah
second largest export of agricultural
products for a country that's half the
size of Indiana you know that's then
you're doing something right there
um but so to come back to the so-called
nitrogen crisis
these natural areas or these natural
preserves that they've said can't change
that that's the idea so they say for
example you know we have a couple of
sand dunes
um that now they've decided they that
the outlook on of those can't change
um in relation to how they looked for
example 25 years ago so it's completely
arbitrary they don't want certain plants
to grow there I don't understand what do
you mean by Sanju a couple sandwiches
like sand I'm just an example but
they're like you know they're certain
Fields where they say that they don't
want a specific type of plan to grow
there or they don't want
um you know the The Meadows to become
forests those governments doesn't want
yeah yeah see so like that's literally
the whole idea of these these protected
areas is that they can't change they
have to look exactly the same as they
did 25 years ago because they are
protected natural preserves
um and the thing is with nitrogen what
nitrogen does is that it promotes plant
growth so it could you could potentially
argue you know if there's a lot of
nitrogen that gets too close to this
Natural Area that maybe certain plants
will start growing there and we don't
want those plants to grow there because
the area is protected that's the crisis
okay see what I'm saying and you know
obviously it's even it remains to be
seen if that is actually if the farmers
actually are responsible for that is
that only that is that the only problem
with the nitrogen that is the does it
not getting into sea water into the
water system is it not a is it is it not
greater issue than just that no they're
already really really good at all of
that so the farmers you know like we
just discussed they're they're
incredibly efficient hard workers and
already very technologically advanced so
you know the Dutch farmers are usually
have been renowned to be incredibly uh
sustainable actually you know very
I would say like probably
technologically top top of their game
when it comes to protecting the area
because obviously no farmer wants their
land to go bad you know especially if
you otherwise you would you would miss
out on well your your income your
revenue and they wouldn't be producing
anymore so it can't be going that so
horribly wrong what is in the mindset of
the politicians who think that the
nitrogen crisis is so dramatic that they
have to bring in policy as dramatic as
halving livestock production that is
huge policy what is going through their
mind do they think that that is a good
idea oh that's the thing so I think that
they don't actually believe that there
is a crisis but that they use this
pretext you know of nitrogen because
otherwise why would you you know we talk
a lot about carbon and things like that
you know ammonia has a small role in
this this whole story as well
um but why would you why would you be so
upset about nitrogen you know the fact
that they chose nitrogen I think is
because it affects the farmers directly
more than any other group in the country
so you know if you use that as a pretext
you know if you switch from phosphate
which apparently didn't work but you go
to nitrous now
and you use that for an actual for a
different agenda than actually the
climate or nature then it starts to make
sense you know so if you start if you
know that the agenda behind it is
something else then it makes sense why
they would choose this okay so what's
the agenda land it's very simple so the
government like I just said the Dutch
word very tiny country we have a massive
population growth due to for example
immigration actually at this very moment
only immigration because the natural
growth of our country is completely
halted
um so but we we are we're packed you
know we don't we have a housing crisis
that we do have and we need new houses
where people can live but there's no
there's no available land so the
government actually says this in a
couple of their own
um in their own reports when they talk
about farmland and when they talk about
potential expropriation they say that
they need housing space you know so
that's one of the reasons and then
obviously if a country for 80 percent
exists of Farmland well then you know
the state doesn't control that
so it would obviously help them very
much if they own more of of the actual
country why are they not having that
conversation I mean you suggested
there's some evidence for it but why
wouldn't they have that conversation
just outright instead of going around
this sort of
which borderline conspiratorial like
well if we take their land by
introducing this we can because people
go around if they tell the truth people
would never accept it you know so if you
if you make up a crisis if you say well
this is for the for the benefit of the
world you know we don't want nature to
go bad it sounds morally you know sound
it sounds good sounds like you're doing
a virtuous thing so if you convince an
entire population or even the entire
world there is a crisis in that well you
we all have to do our part you know we
all have to give up certain rights in
order to solve this then people will
probably be more inclined to politically
accept that and even do it
than when they say oh well actually you
know we just haven't protected our
borders we're letting in too many people
uh we don't have land we don't know what
to do here we need it now so Fork it
over you know and we're gonna start
building houses isn't that too drastic
because if let's say what am I right and
understanding that um net migration into
the Netherlands is something like 400
000 a year so is that correct this year
yeah this year is obviously huge massive
but if 80 of the land of the Netherlands
is for agriculture you don't and so only
20 is for the existing this population
or the rest
you don't need to halve agriculture for
to obtain that you only need a small
amount of land right before that even if
it's 400 000 people you don't need that
much land yeah see you're asking all the
rational questions so but the fact that
you're that to me their true intent is
revealed by asking these types of
rational questions and not getting you
know a rational answer back because if
you if you ask these types of questions
you'd think well that doesn't make any
sense no exactly it doesn't make any
sense so the fact that it doesn't make
any sense shows you that they actually
have a different goal and so the
immigration part I think is one side of
the story definitely you know it has to
do it they they have a problem with
housing of course they do you know they
need more land in order to House people
if you don't protect your borders if you
allow migration record to be broken year
after year which has been the case in
our country
um but there is another aspect and that
is something that I personally think is
maybe even more important it's what do
you want
like for your country like how do you
want your country to look what do you
want
what type of people does the state
function best with in independent
self-reliant hard-working people like
Farmers or people who you know are much
more dependent on the states who
um basically you know are perfect
consumers
I think probably the latter so farmers
as you've seen during the protests as
well you know they're they're a strong
subgroup so the immediate
my immediate thought when you say that
is that Eve and I understand that
Netherlands last year had 105 billion
Euro
revenue from exporting agricultural
Goods I massive
surely the government recognized that by
that that is a huge amount of income for
the company for the company the the
country
why why would they want to jeopardize
that well they'll start focusing on
Alternative forms of you know protein
which is already what they're doing for
which is interesting we have I think
three or four insect Farms now in the
Netherlands and that's something that
they're promoting heavily so I think you
know eventually having that land sure
agricultural you know revenue is big but
having the land and building houses and
selling those for example is also a very
lucrative market and then the government
owns the land and if you own something
you can you know generate Revenue off of
that for yourself for much longer time
than when it actually goes to for
example the farmers because we have a
lot of farmers you know they're fifty
thousand uh farms in the country and
they're not old they're not all major
corporations you know I speak to a lot
of farmers who have maybe 120 cows those
are tinier companies but there are
there's you know you'll if you meet some
Dutch Farmers they're very they're
strong spirited they're very well
organized they know each other I think
together with maybe the Dock Workers
they are the only group self-reliant
group in the country that actually is
able to put up a fight against
government policies and well you know if
we get to our election results
you'll see that that is actually has
been the case they have the manpower to
really derail the government if they
want to and that's not something that I
think any government that aims for power
and control wants okay so I
and this might be a small detail but
with the the point about protein and
insect is it is that is that that new
industry would create more would
generate greater wealth than the current
agricultural no I'm not necessarily
making that claim but okay I mean more
in the sense that They are promoting
different types of you know they're
saying we can do it another way and all
obviously also another guys again of Net
Zero because they're saying that we need
to drastically lower our meat intake for
example so they will come up with all
sorts of alternatives to say you know
you don't have to starve for example but
I think financially you know their
benefit is is a land ownership rather
than necessarily insects for example is
it that there's a a clash of
um World Views or or philosophy so so in
in the Netherlands there's a a proud
history of progressive politics it's one
of the oldest liberal Nations not sure
it's the first but certainly one of the
first and and
um uh what um
there's I think even now there's a party
for the animals it's like there's
there's a green party and there's
um uh sort of proud liberal history
there and I I wonder if if is there is
there a
these current politicians imposing this
policy and actually we should get into
what the policy is
um are they do they
perhaps just have such a drastic
different world view and and concept of
the climate crisis that that's what's
driving this this because that's what
we've we've been seeing in the rest of
the world is is this uh kind of
religious
um following of of climate Apocalypto
that one needs to deal with that and
that that actually that is clouding
their minds and making them
impose
encourage them to impose this policy
that is actually hurting the working
classes and the farmers more than ever
that's what it seems to me yeah to be
going on rather than a plot to kind of
capture more land or change industry
yeah I think it's probably both so I you
know and there are definitely people who
I think truly believe that if we do this
that that helps the climate for example
you know I mean you definitely probably
have people there who are not ill willed
so to say I think there are a lot of
government officials who know better
um but it definitely is a clash of World
Views and actually I think that with
that that actually strengthens maybe the
argument of why our government wants to
get rid of them because they have a
different view of what our country
should look like you know the farmers if
you go to the Dutch Countryside you know
they might not be incredibly politically
outspoken or anything but they're at
hard very conservative people
you usually most people who work with
their hands and who well create food
quite literally you know they're very
literally down to earth people who work
with the knowledge that has been passed
on them through tradition and so most
Dutch Farmers when you'll meet them
they are very sober very you know
they're not people who are going to
spend a ton of money like I said not
perfect consumers they're oftentimes
Christian still
um family oriented you know what
basically the country used to look like
let's say 60 years ago you know you
you'll still find that in the Dutch
Countryside and especially it's embodied
by the farmers so I make this argument
all the time actually that I think that
the Dutch farmers are not just they're
not just Farmers they stand for a
different world view you know produce of
I think actually taking care of the
creation I think most Dutch farmers do
that incredibly well even though the
Liars in The Hague will tell you
something else very very family
well obviously that they're horrible
Peak polluters who destroy our nature
and need to go and you know the the
animal party for example the greens will
say that they that they mistreat their
animals which I find to be like honestly
laughable a joke if you go go to the
forums and you see how I was with the
farmer the other week where he he was
showing me his couch and he was he
called them all by their names you know
he knew them all and then the green will
say that or the animal party but yeah
but we'll kill them later for food well
yes you know not everybody's a vegan not
everybody ascribes to your world view
and what you think morally is correct
but that doesn't mean that these people
are all monsters they're the ones
feeding you you know so I I think I
think that what you are saying is
correct it is a completely different
world view it's not the world view of
you know um the globalist institutions
where we all have to abide by The Net
Zero rules and we all own nothing but we
just share everything and you watch
Netflix all day and you have your nine
to five job behind a computer no
obviously these Farmers lead very very
different lives yeah so maybe that
alternative is exactly what bothers them
you know that that's have you got a
concept of what that cultural uh
division looks like in islands like
we've talked about in America being a
divided nation and you can sort of see
it split and where those divides are
okay what's it look like in Netherlands
is it is it City versus Countryside is
it yeah rural urban yeah yeah it's City
first time it's funny if you even look
if you look at the election results for
example so um this was technically these
were the provincial State elections so
they're we have 12 provinces in the
country and so they're Regional but they
end up indirectly dictating what the
Senate looks like so that's why they're
very very important but they're Regional
and so if you look at the regions
separately the BBB the farmer's party
was the biggest in every single Province
because the countryside you know in
those provinces they go vote and that's
unprecedented we've never seen that
before that one party became the biggest
one in every separate region of the
country but that happened because the
countryside votes because if you then
zoom in on the cities within those
provinces it's it's quite literally you
know you'll see Amsterdam's green left
it says d66 or Democratic party but then
you go maybe you know 10 kilometers 20
kilometers outside of the country and
suddenly it's all BBB again where have
those votes come from which parties have
they moved from they've moved mostly
from the Christian Democratic party so
that used to be you know our it has been
a ruling party for the longest time for
decades and and we actually had a couple
of prime ministers a year or I'd say
should they actually time and time again
in a row really uh coming from that
party it's like you know it used to be
the backbone of our society
moderate Center rights Christian down to
earth type of party but they have
completely abandoned their own people
first of all they're a Christian only a
name
but also the idea of them being a center
right moderate somewhat conservative
party they've completely abandoned and
they they've been working together
mostly with the neoliberals so Market of
this ruling party the vvd and the
Democrats they're honestly they're the
same party I would say the Democratic
party and the vvd so what is it sort of
a technocratic Centrist absolutely
absolutely very very globalist very um
pro-eu oriented towards well I would say
more an international interest than the
interest of of the country itself and
then I think that well if there's
anything that we can really say about
these elections is that the Dutch people
have have said no we don't want that we
do not want that and that's why they
voted for this party
well I want to get to the election and
the implications of what that means but
before that maybe we can just do a
little bit of History to forgive me by
asking any uh simple or ignorant
questions but so we started in 2019
which when the first policy of uh trying
to
address the nitrogen issue with halving
livestock and then that seems that
almost every year since then there's
been new policy always addressing the
nitrogen
crisis so-called and at the same time
um that growing protests uh that you've
talked about that there's been uh such
such uh
Strife or pain amongst Farmers that some
of them have been committing suicide but
I've also read
on the other side that that's certain
politicians in opposition to the farmers
have have been uh people have come to
their house in the night uh uh they've
received abuse
um uh from uh from guest people in
opposition to them uh what What's the
story then since 2019
until this election what what's what
happened so what I if I speak to Farmers
what they say is you know they'll say
well we were initially you know we're
very open to dialogue if there's some
way that we can help you know we they
were they're people of good faith so
they talk to the government about okay
so what can we do you know can we maybe
Implement some some new technological
um Solutions you know what are the the
models that you're using for example to
calculate the nitrogen deposition maybe
maybe the the one that you're using is
not right for it people Dutch people are
very very open usually to compromise and
dialogue you know the word polar culture
is something that is very very pivotal
in our culture and it basically means
exactly that our political landscape is
always characterized by compromise and
Coalition forming what was the word
sorry Paul their culture what does that
mean folder literally means it is the
the construct of the Farmland actually
and you know the the word Escapes Me
escapes me now but like how do you how
do you keep your soil like fertile and
and wet is it irrigation with water yeah
irrigation yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so you know just a little bit more
water a little bit less a little bit
more a little bit less you know that
that's folder culture and so that sort
of very Dutch mindset of compromise you
know that used to be a really I think a
good thing and
um characterizes us as a nation quite
well is now being used against these
Farmers so our government has been I
think fighting a war of attrition with
them where they just change the tune
every single time and the farmers are
like they can't they they don't follow
you know like why how you said first
that we were using this model then we
changed everything accordingly we did
exactly what you asked was now you're
changing the rules again and now you're
changing the rules again and that's how
they feel you know and they and they're
they're trying to again argue with
reason you know and with rational
rational arguments to say this doesn't
make any sense and the government just
doesn't hear them of course they don't
hear them if you know what the real
agenda behind it is and if the end goal
is just know what we want your land you
know then it makes all the sense in the
world but I think it has taken a while
for well maybe even the majority of the
farmers to start realizing that and to
wake up to that fact and and and notice
that the government actually isn't open
to any dialogue isn't open to any other
solution then
um voluntary voluntary sellouts or or
expropriation and they're sick and tired
of it and they have really they're not
just sick and tired it's that's maybe
even two kind way of saying it these
people are at the Ritz end you know they
they see they are subjected to all these
minute rules and regulations so they
can't seem to influence and they're
forced to cut down on their they've
already been forced to cut down on their
livestock every year you know little by
little and it's not just like oh you
know 20 cows need to go that all has a
ripple effect in their businesses you
know they they need to be able to
support themselves as well yeah and like
you said there there are many farmers
who've actually committed suicide
because of this because they just don't
see a way out anymore do you have a
concept of how many
well we had a we had at least four in
the past like six months that I've heard
of but I know of many more many more so
I'm I mean I've spoken to Farmers who
say no there are dozens every year
it seems from a political point of view
that even if
um even if they were right about the
nitrogen crisis that it's such a drastic
policy that that they would see that
they would need to implement
any measures very gradually and help the
farmers with the change is there has
there been any uh
sign of that at all from the Dutch
government no no so the ruling party our
minister of uh stick stuff which is
nitrogen so we actually have a minister
for this
just assuming you know the clown world
that we live in but anyway
um she uh she said no these these goals
are sacred she called them sacred and
even with the elections results coming
in where they you know they suffered a
tremendous loss and this new party
outflanked them by seven seats which is
a lot you know in such a small Senate of
75 in total immediately her response was
well well yeah it's interesting but
nothing can change this is
non-negotiable and she said it with such
arrogance and she had just suffered a
massive loss but these people don't seem
to care you know it's it's it's just
like no sacred
do you think there was a time where the
mood changed in in the Netherlands to
fully support that that this election
result that's happened yeah was that
obviously this is a great marker of of
the change but was there a time before
where it's where it where people who
were maybe unsure about where they stood
and it actually turned on in favor of
the farmers when did when did that last
summer last summer summer of last year
that was when uh well when the protest
became worldwide news also
and I think that was because they the
farmers really took to the streets in a
very almost untouched way like like I
said you know country of compromise of
dialogue all the time we are not the
French no we don't Riot we uh we don't
go on strikes
um honestly also most Farmers never
would want to go on strikes and don't
want to go to protest because they have
a company to run you know it's not like
they can just afford it to take off uh
for or take their a couple weeks off to
go and protest the government they that
they'd be shooting themselves in the
foot right so they we're not the French
we don't do that but then this summer
I think because they were so at their
wit's end
um there was a they United and they went
out in the streets and they protested in
a very well quite radical way for a
Dutch standards so they took their
tractors out in the street which is
obviously very like power it's powerful
imagery to see so many people in their
tractors out on the street bugging
blocking for example the highways
blocking distribution centers and I
think the blocking of the distribution
centers which is what they did that woke
quite a fair amount of people up because
I think in this distribution of War
um sorry supermarkets Supermarket so you
know like we we're modern day people we
half the time we don't realize where our
food comes from you know we go to the
supermarket we don't have to do anything
for it I mean we pay an amount an insane
amount for it nowadays with the
inflation but we don't have to work for
our food it's a given you know we take
it for granted
um so a lot of people don't realize that
those Farmers actually you know produce
their everyday nutrition for them but
when the farmers went out in the summer
and they blocked those distribution
centers for the supermarkets within a
couple of hours the milk and the eggs
were gone from the supermarket and those
shelves stayed empty and I think that
that was a really really powerful image
you know no Farmers no food that was
really something that stuck with people
and and the idea of expropriation
is something indeed so radical you know
that even the most you know politically
inactive Dutch person would be like oh
oh the government taking away your
private property I don't know if that's
a good idea and these protests were very
very successful and they gained a lot of
attention especially because the Dutch
State cracked down on them with violence
and I think that was what caused a big
shift in the mindset of of the Dutch did
they deploy the military they deployed
military and uh and a lot of police
forces and it all came to a head when at
a certain point one of the of the
I think of the protest site which was at
I think on a highway there was a young
boy in a tractor who who's there with
his family and he was driving a tractor
and he was driving away from the protest
and this kid got shot at by the police
like you know crazy crazy 16 years old
he was uh
yeah no no a real bullet a real bullet
not rubber like a appropriate it
thankfully thank God he wasn't hit his
tractor got hit but so you could see the
dent from where the bullet had hit the
tractor and you know he the boy was
completely traumatized by the event
obviously and then media came and they
shot the photo of the boy sitting in the
tractor and it would have been a matter
of two centimeters or he could have been
killed and the fact that that happened
then they lost the public then
presumably I mean in the so-called free
Democratic Society where people
supposedly have the right to go out and
protest these people were not violent
they you know they were they they're not
carrying any weapons they're not armed
and the fact that police officers shot
at a child
yeah it shows you the incentives do you
think that it was a police officer like
a
particularly sort of funny character or
do you think that he in any do you think
the police officer represented the
attitude of the rest of the of the
forces then I think he represented
maybe not the attitude of all the other
police officers on the ground I think
generally speaking you know I've said
this before I think most police officers
who are patrolling on the streets who go
to these protests who were with us for
example at the rally just last weekend
most people support the farmers but they
get orders you know and they get orders
from their superiors who listen to The
Establishment to the ministry of justice
and I think there the orders were very
very clear you know our prime ministers
allegedly has called our farmers and I
wouldn't be surprised if it's true
and a pain in the ass you know
behind closed doors and I think of
course that's how he talks about them so
I can only imagine that when they're
briefed you know when the police force
is in the military are briefed on these
protests that they use strong language
and that they are like let's let's get
these people out of here as soon as
possible because obviously the protests
were very successful very very
successful and if you want your policies
to survive then you can't have the
public opinion shift so they tried
incredibly hard to have that not happen
with the help of I would say well most
of the mainstream media in the
Netherlands also you know the their
efforts oh the efforts to vilify the
farmers have been incredibly extensive
really all the way even at that point
even of the yeah the shooting yeah
absolutely absolutely because then
they'll say you know I even heard you
mention it just now a couple of minutes
ago you said something about that there
were people who went to
um like some government officials houses
Etc to talk yeah is that true which is
yeah that's true but you know if you see
how the media writes about it
and the the real story is that they went
and they said could we potentially ask
you some questions about the policies
because we have some solutions and we
would like to discuss them you know none
of it was threatening violence or
anything and obviously there's one story
that they brought to a specific vegan
politician a sack of meat yeah in the
middle of the night yeah very
intimidating hang on a sec that is not
appropriate no but appropriate I mean I
get it right but the thing if anyone
comes to your door in the middle of the
night it's intimidating I don't think it
was in the middle of the night it was an
evening obviously it was dark but um you
know it was all taped uh and I saw it
and I mean if you're a politician I can
imagine that you don't want people at
your door but sure thing or anyone yeah
yeah you might not want people at your
door but you if you are a farmer you
might want the government out of your
house and out of your property you know
like I think in a sense we need to see
this in relationship to each other so if
imagine everything that you've ever
worked for is going to be taken away
from you by these people they're
completely desperate completely
unwilling to reason with you you're not
hurt either they're trying to bleed you
dry your your your your friends your
family are going insane you know people
are committing suicide you're about to
lose everything that you've ever worked
for and you show up to a politician's
house in Despair and you say can I talk
to you and then you are vilified as the
as the evil the bad guy in the story you
know that that's how the media portrays
it and and I'm sorry but I will say no I
think that I think it's fair
I would go very far to protect my my
property and my life and my family if if
somebody wanted to take it away and uh
you know the fact that farmers have
never actually been violent I think
shows you what type of people they are
and they're good people at heart well
I'm interested by the media the media
aspect so you have media completely
coming off the off the farm and yet now
we have this rally last week as you
described the mood is completely shifted
what was the mood at the at the rally
actually was very very positive and it
was it just Farmers or was it farmers
and citizens citizens the the the
protest was organized by both a Citizens
movement and the farmer's movement so
the farmers defense Forest they were one
of the organizers and the other one was
called together for the Netherlands so
it was a group it was a mixed group of
both farmers and uh just civilians who
were concerned in general with the
government's policies so one of the
slogans basically of the rally and and
leading up to the elections has been
stems which means vote them out so that
was the General sense of the of the
valley was vote the current
establishment out so that they don't get
the majority in the Senate and hopefully
won't be able to push any of these new
laws and what so the media then that
have been against the farmers throughout
and uh this the last few years how have
they covered the rally and the elections
well are they dealing with it they're
not dealing with it very well so the
rally you know there was I think there
was one instance where a farmer on a
trucker on a tractor sorry uh knocked
over fence you know and then that was
the main headline it's like oh you know
they're using violence no nothing else
happened if you were there it was
completely I thought actually the it
almost felt like a festival at a certain
point because people were happy the Sun
was shining and we had just had a
horrible weather
um the mood was really calm like really
actually nice it was almost enjoyable
you know people were just in really good
mood and we had all sorts of great
speakers I spoke myself and it was it
was it was a very exhilarating event in
a way because people felt you know we
can do this we're here with a lot of
people we're going to stand up it was an
exciting time and then well the
elections came and well the
establishments suffered a big big blow
yeah and now they're doing the same
story over and over again you know it's
the this BBB party which is actually
quite a moderate party I personally at
least think so they're trying to say oh
they're so it's far right you know and
the whole all tragedy is the same we've
seen it we've seen it for years and they
just try and do it again so the
vidification process you know has
started and I don't know by the media
Yeah Yeah by the media and I don't think
that people will fall for it again it's
just like it's the wind's too big you
know they can try all they want so then
what are the implications of this
election what do you think this means
for the Netherlands so at the the like I
said the the elections were provincial
but they're very important because they
do indirectly dictate what our Senate is
made up of so which parties and now the
ruling parties have completely lost
their majority in the Senate and our
Senate is a chamber of reflection that
holds a lot of power
so we have obviously the parliament you
know our house basically of Commons um
and then Senate Our House of Lords and
they both have equal voting powers on
laws so they need to pass through both
Chambers in order to come into Force so
if the Senate doesn't want you know to
vote in favor of a party that the
government proposed in Parliament where
they have a majority then it's not going
to happen
and so with this you know if they want
to push new law that allows for for
example expropriation which is currently
not legal
they can block it they can block it ah
okay yeah so it's massive it's it's
really really important but then we'll
have to see how it goes obviously with
the Coalition formation process
um like I said the government has lost
its majority but with the help maybe of
the labor and green party and some other
tinier more Fringe extreme left parties
they could potentially still gather a
majority for these policies so we're not
completely out of the woods yet oh I see
yeah do you think that the BBB are a
party here to stay or are they sort of
single policy single issue party that
are going to deal with this specific
cause or what do you think the future
looks like for them I think they're
definitely they have the potential to
stay because the the woman who leads the
party is very down to earth you know
um almost I would say in a way almost
old-fashioned politician in the sense
that she's just a common sense you know
no no-nonsense type of woman and I think
that appeals to a large
um part of the Dutch population but
she's she's very informal in the way
that she speaks so she also gains you
know people she's funny almost also like
in the way that she talks and and she's
she's I think she's likable
that what I think it will depend on is
how well she delivers Carolina from the
plus Carolina okay so it depends on how
well she delivers so the thing is is
that this party is actually not
fundamentally opposed to nitrogen
policies in a way that for example I am
so I've always taken the more radical
stance of saying none of this is real
you know it's it's a manufactured crisis
in order to take away our rights which
we've seen happen during covet for
example you know and fear-mongering in
order to get people to give up their
rights
um I think that this is the same but
just you know with a different subject
so Caroline from the plus takes a
different approach he says no the mo the
models that are being used are faulty
which they are you know they're faulty
and so she says we need more time to
implement these measures and we need
different calculations they're faulty
but not without some Merit like she
would accept that there's a nitrogen
crisis yes she accepts that narrative
and that's where I personally am a
little bit worried because if you know
if you realize really truly what the
government wants to do here and what
their aim is if you get stuck within a
circle of lies and you debate within the
allowed narrative then I'm not sure that
you're going to win but maybe you know
I'm obviously I'm a political
commentator I stand from the sideline
she's in the system maybe this is her
strategy maybe she thinks that this way
you know they will gain time and the
government will again have to reveal its
true colors because it obviously won't
accept uh other models to be used to to
calculate the nitrogen deposition and
maybe she's hoping that that will wake
even more people up to the fact that oh
if this is nonsensical and that their
party therefore will grow as an
opposition party
um it could grow or they could the
Netherlands could be greater than even
more radical party extremist party that
that sometimes happened if they're not
listened to yeah that could happen too
how she's going to deliver and who she
won parade with cause you know we have
what this could mean now with the Senate
potentially blocking all these new
policies we could have new national
elections coming soon if the cabinet
Falls over this which is you know
imaginable then we'll have a new
elections very soon and and if Ruta is
voted out of office finally hopefully I
pray to God on my bare knees that he
will be then then we'll have to see who
she wants to be potentially even ruling
with you know if she becomes so she
could be the next prime minister of the
Netherlands not I mean potentially
possibly if we see the results now if
she if these were the national elections
she would have been the largest and then
she would have been the candidate the
you know for for Prime ministership yeah
is there any uh link to this with your
skepticism is this tied in any way to EU
policy it's with the far the Pharma
movement a bit is there a Euro skeptic
nature to it at all what what's this
what's the mood there absolutely yes all
the farmers they they say okay
we are being ruled and not by The Hague
but we are being ruled by Brussels and
that is something that obviously is
incredibly upsetting we you know the the
sense of not being a Sovereign Nation
anymore the government is hiding behind
EU regulations obviously you know they
have their own national interests as to
why they want the pharmacist they're
using EU law for it so yeah you know it
at heart is this fight again I think
from you know a national interest versus
a more globalist or EU Centrist sort of
world view
um so it's completely at the core of it
absolutely do you think this could turn
into a is there any chance of the
Netherlands leaving the EU is it is that
is that too distant on the agenda I
think it's it's still we probably need a
few more years for that um so this
Farmer's party for example says that
they're not in favor of an exit we would
call ours a nexit
um I am 100 in favor of nexit uh but the
you know the media coverage that for
example the UK has had with brexit if
you talk to anybody you know who isn't
who doesn't read any alternative Media
or doesn't read even UK press everyone
in the Netherlands thinks that you guys
are completely you know lost and that
everything is going to hell here because
of brexit and so that image has really
stuck with the Dutch and they're afraid
so we you know we get told all the time
oh we're too tiny of a country to be
able to do it by ourselves we would ruin
our entire economy if we relieve the EU
so I think the majority of the Dutch
population is not ready sadly for an
exit yet but you are oh oh I would be I
would I would love to be the new Nigel
farage I would take that role on any any
second yeah what's the Dutch case for
nexit
I mean it's the same as yours eventually
it's a matter of democracy of
sovereignty do you want Brussels and
some bureaucrats there to dictate what
your country looks like or do you want
to do it yourself I mean I think it
really it quite literally is that simple
do you want to have control over your
own borders do you want to have control
over what your own landscape looks like
how your farmers are regulated uh how
much immigration you allow all of that
comes back to the EU you know the
majority of our laws currently are being
drafted in the EU and while the
Democratic legitimation of those are um
are very slim I think personally so yeah
I would 100 say we should have left
yesterday instead of tomorrow so well
maybe that's still after the farmer's
situation has been resolved that'll be
your next uh uh it will result the Virus
issue too yeah yeah of course I mean if
we get if we
then we're no longer bound to these
ridiculous nature 2000 rules for example
and then our government what's the next
two thousand those are the the natural
reserves or The Preserves that need to
be protected that our government's Now
using to enforce the nitrogen policy so
they're basing it on these EU
regulations but if you're not if you're
no longer part of the EU then you know
they would have to just push push these
laws themselves and then you know that
wouldn't fly it clearly already isn't
flying so uh okay yeah okay so let me
ask you about Net Zero if I may if I
still have to we have time uh um so
you're here in London to make the case
um against NetZero now if in in Britain
whether it's mainstream politics or
mainstream media the conversational Net
Zero skips whether or not Net Zero is a
good idea straight to how do we
Implement Net Zero and and
um Theresa May in 2019 uh committed to
Net Zero by 2050 and the successive
government since then have all backed it
what's the case against
Net Zero well I mean it will basically
I'll go back to what I've been saying
about the Dutch Farmers the case against
Net Zero shouldn't be you know do we do
it in 2040 do we do it in 2050 how can
we reach it the case should be
not even is this necessary but
we should just say no we see through
what your actual agenda here is and and
I think that's why you should just say
you know you shouldn't debate within the
circle of lies that they allow you to
debate in but you should say no no we
see what you're doing here you know this
Net Zero plan is not actually about
saving the climate or avoiding the world
from being destroyed it is a political
decision that is used to crack down on
people's freedom and people's rights
that's what I think Net Zero is exam
again same same mechanism as with covid
but Net Zero is a more efficient one
basically because it affects all of us
if you have an entire population that is
led to believe that our world will be
destroyed within uh you know Greta
tunberg in 2018 said that we would
already be probably wiped off the face
of the earth now
but if you get especially the youth to
believe that and if you get people
afraid then of course you're going to be
able to implement all of these rules
that will restrict our personal freedoms
you know like the 15-minute cities like
the uh the cars that we no longer will
be allowed to drive
um maybe even potentially personal
carbon Credit Systems you know so I
think I've always taken the line we
shouldn't debate within that premise we
should see it for the pretext that it is
that is being used for a different
agenda an agenda that is oriented to or
on control rather than the climate so
Dutch farmers are you know the nitrogen
policies are also part of Net Zero it's
it's all in this it's all the same idea
well so this week the um the ipcc
released uh their new report I think
it's the sixth report now I've only
skimmed it but from first glances it's
more alarmist than the last one from
2014. so they are very much making the
case that's the UN that uh not only is
climate change uh uh human caused by
humans which I don't think anyone really
argues what they argue is actually how
bad is it and and how how bad is it for
us to implement the Net Zero I guess I'm
sort of assuming you agree with that
that you do think that climate change
exists and that it's human it's human
it's caused by humans but that actually
it's it's not as bad as everyone thinks
and that it needs to be um dealt with
uh but without hurting people I think
the apocalyptic narrative is incredibly
dangerous and is a is a means of
political control so it's you know
fear-mongering and especially in the
world that is completely secular
um watch the Western world is becoming
more and more so it has really taken I
feel the place of a new religion but not
in a in none of the good senses of you
know the word
um so
I think people are very susceptible to
the idea of
finding meaning through you know
preserving the planet and saving the
world in that sense so they're more
focused on the creation rather than on
the Creator so to say and I think that
that's dangerous because that can be
used for that can be abused and misused
by people who have a different agenda
that is actually way more Sinister and
you know I think
with the climate agenda we've seen that
already before we've seen the
fear-mongering my parents told me about
acid rain you know when I was a bit
younger they were talking about the
ozone layer
um now you know it's the rising sea
levels but it all seems to be not
actually quite as bad as they make it
out to be so then you have to wonder why
you know why would they why would they
be doing that and are there
even if we assume that what they're
saying is true
is the solution that they are proposing
the right one I think that's what's
interesting to me is that is the
solution they're proposing the right one
and if you read Klaus Schwab's books
it's they they
it's you get the impression that they've
identified or he identifies
uh climate climate change as a crisis
that's kind of unsolvable except if we
seed power to those uh enlightened
um and and annoying self-anointed Elite
right and that's where the the sort of
the difficulty seems to be yeah rather
than uh
uh in in policy where it's like okay
well there is change and we but
everyone's a part of
the change it's it's actually no we need
to hand over everything to them that
seems to me to be the Crux of her it's
always yeah yeah it's always a rules for
rules for thee but not for me type of
situation and I mean you know we can
talk about the examples forever but all
these climate
um meetings that they have you know they
always come in their private jets but
then you know somebody who works their
nine to five job uh pays I don't know up
to half of their their income in taxes
uh that wants to go on holiday once a
year to Spain to forget about you know
their miserable life though that that
man can't do that they can't have their
meat at the dinner table anymore you
know but they get to eat
Stakes travel around the world maybe
potentially even buy their carbon credit
you know by the time that that comes
into existence which I think it will
because you know it's being very very
openly discussed it I think this will be
a sort of Neo feudalist system where for
some people everything will be possible
but for others nothing is this what you
back at the beginning of the
conversation you you used the term
perfect consumers is that what is that
sort of tied into this Neo feudalist
concept I wanted to ask what what is a
perfect consumer what what is that a
reference to yeah so I think that's
that's basically the the goal or what
you know the globalist institutions of
this world people like Klaus Schwab that
you just you know refer to want us to be
because if you are a perfect consumer
who doesn't believe in anything higher
then well either the government the
climate or whatever crisis they you know
choose to to fly with in that period of
time
um but that is what consumes you and you
consume their products then you're you
know your perfect Cash Cow for the
establishment for the system obviously
somebody who's hard working
um who wants to serve a higher purpose
in life who wants to have a family who
pays attention to what they spent their
money on and doesn't live a completely
materialistic life is much much less
good candidate to be a perfect consumer
than somebody who's completely isolated
doesn't have a moral or philosophical
fundament you know it doesn't have a
national identity of that so I think
yeah probably the where's the perfect
consumer think narrative come from is
that is that from the wvf is that
because I've not I've not come across
that I mean I don't think that they
would call it that no you know they
obviously want to tell you that you're
completely free Sovereign being and that
you're doing the right thing and that
you know you owe nothing and you'll be
happy type of narrative you know that is
something that comes from them and I
call it you will be the perfect consumer
because that's what they actually see
you as you know they don't see you as a
free individual with rights that are
endowed upon you by your creator they
see you as somebody that they can make
money off of and if you are too critical
of the government and if you see through
their actual plans you won't be that so
of course you want to numb people you
want to dumb them down you want to
subdue them you know and you want to
make them believe that this modern day
lifestyle is is what will actually make
you happy because then you're easy to
control and so it is your hypothesis
that what we're seeing in the
Netherlands with the Dutch Pharma
results is the first or one of the first
not the first maybe but one of the first
uh revolts against that ideology yeah I
think so I think that's what it
symbolizes and that's why I'm you know
even though maybe politically speaking I
don't put all of my Salas in the
political party system you know I don't
know if this BBB party will live up to
its claims if it um if they don't just
find a way around it
but the fact that the people you know
went out in such fast numbers to vote
for a party that literally has the word
farmer in its name you know that's
amazing that's that's why I'm excited
about this because it shows you that you
know maybe not everybody wants to be the
perfect consumer and we are not just
going to sit back and allow it to happen
and and you know have
live our live our lives in our 15-minute
cities and then eat uh manufactured food
or printed 3D printed meats and insects
and and watch all stupid woke Netflix
shows Etc you know maybe some people
want some a different type of life and I
think in a small sense this is this
shows that it reflects that people
actually don't want that type of life at
all well on that incredibly positive
note over vladinger's Brook thank you so
much for speaking with me it's been
fascinating no it was fun very fun thank
you so much
[Music]
thank you
foreign